[Music]
47 years they've waited for this seeing
West Ham in a European final again but
just 5 000 tickets were allocated for
them thousands came just to be here
they didn't come to Prague for this
being ambushed by Fiorentina Ultras in
the back streets of the city center
from inside one bar in video obtained by
Sky News the Italians can be seen
unleashing weapons and fireworks on West
Ham supporters
chairs are thrown back seemingly in
self-defense the clashes were contained
to this street five miles from the
stadium
but inside the stadium it was Fiorentina
players targeted by West Ham fans
objects were thrown during the first
half leaving fiorentina's Captain
blooded the match was paused a warning
to respect the players was issued by the
stadium announcer West Ham thought
they'd conceded as half-time approached
but was saved by VAR
and another favorite video review came
after the break a penalty awarded and
converted by Sade Ben Rama but they LED
for only five minutes until jacoma
bonaventura Drew level for Fiorentina
a game tense with few chances extra time
loomed Jared Bowen had other ideas in
the 90th minute Celia 2-1 win for West
Ham the Europa conference League ending
the East London as 43 year drought
without a major trophy it's been
fantastic mate and it's been brilliant
Spirits all day the Italian fans have
been fantastic
I don't want it to end no I mean God
bless you everyone cheers Champions
champions
thank you
I know what hasn't been a decision but
I'm buzzing
my voice is gone it's been a great night
and uh I'm just happy that we've
actually won a trophy a season when West
Ham were fighting relegation ends here
in European Glory David Moyes becomes
the first British manager in 15 years to
win a European trophy lifting it though
might be the last act for Captain
declares before a big money move
West Hammer moving up in the football
World themselves after so long the
Hammers can call themselves champions
again Rob Harris Sky News Prague